i'm looking through the paper trying to
find the right symbol for you um i guess
we've got two choices we've got phi
which is the order parameter
um and that's quite important for this
work but probably the most important
thing in this work is it's just how hard
we're shaking it and that's the
amplitude age so i think probably a
capital a
when i'm building just a like a cell
it's a box i'm building a box and we're
going to put
glass beads basically sand in the box
i've got a whole range of different
boxes so this one obviously is a square
box i have a long thin box
bigger boxes over there i've got some
some glass boxes as well which are quite
nice the box i'm making
is the box we used for our recent
publication um which is a result i'm
pretty excited to to show you because
it's
it really speaks a lot about the kind of
physics that we do down here and and why
it's interesting well what we've got
here is just a piston it's a shaker
we play
a sound wave into it and it the
amplifier turns that into a vibration
and that's what we're going to use to
shake the sand up and down
these are little glass beads so silicate
beads
which i've
sieved to get the right size and then
we've cleaned them so what's lovely let
me just turn that around
is that they really they look like a
liquid and they flow like a liquid
so we're not so poor as we can't afford
proper
funnels and cones but the paper one is
brilliant it works so well and
when it gets dirty you can just make
another one so
and then it's just a question of
putting a lid on and it turns out for
this experiment the lid's incredibly
important
not least because all the particles
would fly everywhere without the lid
this is just a little box which
generates a signal so it's generating a
60hz signal which you can't see
there we are that's a 60hz signal
for those of you who remember your high
school maths what i want is a sine wave
okay so this is a sine wave signal and
i'm going to put that through
an amplifier this is not much different
to a stereo at home just produces
much more current so more power for the
piston and then that goes out the back
and into the piston
and what this sine wave that we have on
the screen
we get on the piston as well so typical
setup for this experiment is to start
with a nice homogeneous distribution of
the particles so there's no special
place in the tray it's the same
everywhere and
when i switch it on very gently when i'm
shaking it very very gently just by
turning this dial here
and we can see that the particles turn
from being
stuck to the bottom to being a gas of
particles so if you think about the air
in this room it's just a bunch of
molecules oxygen and nitrogen and carbon
dioxide and a few other trace elements
just bouncing around bouncing off each
other and all of those molecules are at
equilibrium with the walls the
temperature of the walls and the
radiation from the lights and from the
sunlight
and that's what defines their
temperature and their velocity
in this system
what we've got is a bunch of particles
which are being vibrated up and down
they're forming a gas and
well they don't really have such a thing
as a temperature because temperature is
something we define at equilibrium that
means that they're balanced with the
walls this can't be balanced with walls
because the walls are shaking up and
down so hard that there's no such thing
as as equilibrium instead what we have
is a thing called steady state
so
what that means is that the velocity of
the particles the the nature of the gas
the temperature if you like
is given not by
an equilibrium with the walls but with
an energy balance where the amount of
energy lost in the collisions between
particles is the same as the amount of
energy that the shaking base is putting
in
now this is where this starts to get
really interesting and this is really
what the paper that we've just published
is all about as i turn up how hard i'm
shaking this so i'm just going to shake
it harder and harder and harder
what we're going to see
here we go there's a little bit of
physics magic coming up here
shake it harder
there it is
okay so that's quite bizarre because if
you think about the gas in a room
when it's at equilibrium
it certainly doesn't suddenly or collect
in one corner of the room if that
happened we'd all be doomed to suffocate
randomly when the gas collected so this
is behaving like a gas
but not really because it's all
collecting up in one corner as we shake
it harder now if i shake it even harder
here we go and take it up
you can see it's getting going to hear
that it's getting harder
and eventually
we go back to a nice homogeneous
distribution again but what's going on
is at low amplitudes of oscillation when
we're not shaking it very hard
then the particles are moving around
chaotically
and they're acting like a gas
so we can talk about the temperature of
the particles and we can understand the
physics in terms of it simply being a
gas
but when we
start to shake it really hard
then everything changes and this was a
real surprise because nobody had
considered this before and what happens
is instead of moving around randomly the
particles will start to move around just
as a plane of
of a single block moving up and down and
this this coherent motion
has a much higher temperature
in terms of
granular temperatures
than than the gas had before and so
there's a jump this there's an immediate
step when the particles go from being
chaotically driven to being coherently
driven where the temperature just goes
up hugely
and that change in temperature does
something really quite bizarre if it
forces a region where if you get more
particles in one cluster the pressure
goes down
now that's counter-intuitive normally
when you get more stuff the pressure
goes up just think about what i was
going to say think about the police
kettling protesters but maybe not a very
good example
think about you know you just squeeze a
gas it gets hotter
but in this case when you put more
particles in the pressure goes down but
what that means is that because the
pressure's gone down more particles want
to go there and so the more particles
that go there the lower the pressure
gets and then more particles rush in
because the pressure's low and
eventually you rebalance the whole
system with loads of particles all
clustered into one space and a whole
region of nothingness going on around it
so this is really bizarre because what i
started out by talking about
is chaotic motion of particles this is
chaos dynamics it's a region of physics
which is quite well understood very
interesting region of physics and what i
end up talking about
is
more the random motion of particles and
statistical
mechanics and this is a completely
separate area of physics
the area that we're looking in the area
of of parameter space that we're looking
in this density of particles um this
size of box is very specific
and if we we found it we were lucky
that's the truth of it
it would have been very very easy to
miss it it would have been very easy to
simply assume we've done the experiment
wrong because the reality is that you
look at this experiment
and you think okay well it's most likely
that we've got it
slanted and so all of the particles are
flowing down the slope and we spent a
long time these bolts
are a way of making sure that the
experiment is completely level we spent
a long time with a spanner and a a
spirit level just trying to make sure
that this experiment was completely
level and
once we were completely convinced we did
the experiment again and the bubble
comes again and in fact if you do the
experiment in a computer simulation
then the bubble still comes and the
computer simulation is of course
definitely flat you can know that that's
flat so
we're pretty confident that this is a
real effect
it of course it happens in nature shock
waves due to resonances between
particles are all over the place um even
when an organ is playing a note it's a
shock wave traveling down the tube of
the organ it's basically the same piece
of physics as we're looking at here
but in an organ pipe there's not room
for the separation
granular dynamics in general
it's not a good conversation piece for
parties because people look at it and
think well that's really quite dull
but actually it's everywhere it's
everywhere from grain silos for farmers
to ingredients for pharmaceutical
companies uh ingredients for food
companies you don't really want a pizza
which is all tomato and
no anchovy um or maybe you do um
it's it's also
in space the smaller bodies in the solar
system things like asteroids and moons
and the dust on the surface of the moon
these are all granular systems sand
dunes i can keep naming examples all day
as a pure physicist
not thinking about applications not
worrying about that sort of thing but
just interested in
the equations and what's going on this
is really fantastic and yes we're at the
beginning of a subject so we don't
really see its applications
but the applications will follow because
nobody would doubt that the applications
of thermodynamics are definitely there
and
give this another five or ten years
there'll be applications there's no
worries about that